hey
got a permit for those guns
i've got your permit right here
permit
denied
[Music]
i spent money i don't have
to do these documents it's gonna take me
months
and you better get started
wow i just got a big headache
when i was like hit by a train or
something i didn't see anything
oh i forgot to tell you i hung out with
your friend janine this weekend
i hope she's doing your brother right
now you big-headed buffoon
no no no no you got more
anyway the sooner you
get back to
uh work the sooner you'll be
partnerized i taste [__] you do
stacy
did you
put [__] in my lunch
oh
i'm gonna get going now sir
[Music]
winter
is cancelled
ah
[Music]
have a happy summer
so
you want to play
[Music]
getting down and dirty with a procyon
loader
got no people skills but he's good with
motors that weird thing by his side an
infantilized sequoia the two of them who
walk by people say oh boy they ask me
why i'm bringing a baby into battle
that's really irresponsible and getting
them around i said give me a break get
off of my back dammit i didn't learn
parenting my daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome aboard the night 2000
it's like darth vader's bathroom
it is a one-of-a-kind car
it is the fastest safest strongest car
in the world it is also completely fuel
efficient and is operated entirely by
microprocessors which make
in these
[Music]
are
afraid
[Music]
some people need to help
somebody it's gonna be
[Music]
oh
always here
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
once these idiots get out of the water
it's not as if the fish are gonna follow
them home
you went back in the water
you little ginger [__]
[Music]
to help somebody when the air just
surrenders inside
won't you worry
[Applause]
[Music]
holy [__]
i'm getting old
forever
[Music]
oh no
how will we ever get back to bikini
bottom now
i can take you there
[Music]
who are you i'm david hasselhoff
so where's your boat
boat
[Music]
next stop bikini bottom
[Applause]
okay fellas this is where you get off
bikini bottoms directly below but we'll
never be able to float down in time who
said anything about
floating
the initiating launch sequence
[Music]
did you see that the control
all hands on decks
no
[Music]
you're done good hasselhoff you're done
now
[Music]
everybody gets a chance
clap your hands just party time
[Music]